in certain rain and Rush of water from
the hilly region along with tidal search
in the last few days have caused
widespread damage in Fort District of
chatagram Hill region of Southeast
Bangladesh many areas including cities
and towns are submerged including Cox's
Bazaar where nearly a million rohingya
refugees live sabira begum says she
barely escaped from the Crackdown in
Myanmar with her family of five in 2017.
now she has to deal with the pain of
losing two of her closest family members
my two and
two and her granddaughter both died due
to landslides they were buried in the
mud I'm feeling emotionally down and
upset and missed them so much
according to the official figure there
have been more than 100 Landslide
related incidents in the rohingya camps
alone and more than 1500 makeshift homes
were damaged or destroyed due to bad
weather in Cox's Bazaar some of the
refugees were taken to shelters others
were left to fend for themselves Hamid
Hussein is trying his best to fix this
damaged home like many others here
it's been raining very heavily the last
few days in the camp and our shelters
are located on the slab of the hills we
can't live like this with all the
various difficulties
officials say at least 30 000 people are
stranded in banderban and more than 200
000 people are trapped in Cox's Bazaar
District because of floods and
landslides the flood have washed away
many houses crops and other assets many
people are in desperate need of food and
drinking water
who lost their home is now living with a
relative
due to the heavy rain we couldn't
Salvage most of our belongings
many here are spending their days in
fear with no signs of the monsoon rain
easing the matter of this hearsay there
will be more incessant rain in coming
days which could make things worse in
the choctagon hill tracks region of
Southeastern Bangladesh
there are many shelters open in the
affected areas the government has now
deployed members of the army to help
local authorities with relief and
Salvage operations Bangladesh